big is making Kelly a short new hairdo
that really scared dog chomp away from
doing the debate in Iowa which he's
moderating it's fierce I got to say very
clear strong I love it it looks
fantastic and a Megan told our senior
news editor Jennifer perils that it's
her power cut and the two talked about
the new do politics and lots of other
issues including Parenthood and staying
in shape
it's the softer side of megyn kelly you
have to ask your former colleagues Sarah
Palin has recently come out to endorse
him so what are thoughts on that who
could take their eyes off of it right
she knows how to make a splash in that
little cute little camisole it was very
sparse there's perfect
she is the television phenom as is he so
to watch the two of them next to each
other the dynamic was just riveting it's
great television Trump pasta could be
our next president so what are your
thoughts right now that you're going up
head to head with him so hard right now
he's gonna get over this by then he will
be back when he needs you that's over it
he will be fine I will be fine in
America will be just fine to his comedy
has made about women and working mothers
in virtually I think it's ironic that he
does have a successful working daughter
who was a mother of now raised three
children I know somebody who knows Trump
very well and he was on a private plane
with Trump years ago and he tells the
story about how an 11 year old Ivanka
came over and needed Trump's attention
and Trump is in the middle of this
meeting with these other powerful
executives and the other executives
expected him to blow off the daughter
Ivanka but he didn't he blew them off
and he stopped and she said she needed
help with her homework and he walked to
a didn't part of the plane with her and
he sat down with her and they attended
to her needs I think that story speaks
beautifully of him and the woman she is
today speaks beautifully I panicked
your Vanity Fair article um cover
absolutely beautiful we'd love the hair
by the way thank you we are huge fans of
it during empowering it's gone whoa do
you feel like a little bit more lighter
and just easy breezy and I don't feel
lighter because it's January and you
know as much as I tried to do that I'm
gonna lose five pounds this January I
just went right back to eating my kids
goldfish and yeah pretzels but there's
something psychological about cutting
your hair off I don't know what it is
but I love it there's something about it
that is just empowering and makes you
feel like your best and strongest self